just out of reach huh hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to layers
of fear now this is an indie horror game
or maybe it's not but it's an early
access right now and usually that means
stay away probably not very good but
it's overwhelmingly positively rated and
everyone has asked me to play it so with
that being said I'm gonna get going and
I also discovered because I started up
to see what it was like usually I do
with these indie horror games just to
see is it good but there's a surprise
because the torment I have to endure I
still hear the scratching in my head
deeper and my hands cut so many times on
broken bottles each night drowning in a
cold sweat but there is a way
way to bring back what life took from me
the only precious thing every portrait
that is painted with feeling is a
portrait of the artist not of the sitter
Oscar Wilde picture the painting of the
Picture of Dorian Gray anyway that I
think I'm not entirely sure 100% but
that sounds a lot like Patton Oswald and
whenever I think of Patton Oswalt I
think of ratatouille which is my
favorite favorite Pixar movie down into
the basement on a dark stormy day our
three little rascals chanced for a stray
goody goody gumdrops okay so anyway this
is as far as I got I just loaded it up
and I noticed that it's gorgeous like
this game is beautiful this is so well
done and this is a dog muscle I saw this
but just look at this look at this whoa
hey I saw you I didn't vote
there's a rat there's a rat in here
Patton Oswalt did Brad - Brad who's my
favorite Oh an artist triumph gallery
opening
Wow scrit --ax I'm calling the new
Caravaggio others compared him to Van
Eyck and one awestruck critic who wishes
to remain unnamed when as far to his
invoke the Great Spirit the spirit of
the great Leonardo anyway you're
slightly the exhibition moved in immense
success okay so I'm assuming that's
about me dear sir we would like to ask
you to cease bothering our pest control
specialists as well as refrain from
sending us any more of your highly
inappropriate letters I'll have you know
that my mother is a respectable woman
and does not take kindly to such
accusations all of our employees have
visited your house reported absolutely
no signs of rodent infestation of any
kind and as such decided not to act it
further than a prophylactic spraying
please treat this letter as a final
warning or else in ektu envelope you'll
proceed will be from our lawyers with
best regards Carl Denton pesky pests
pacification coat okay I read them okay
so apparently this guy's got a rodent
problem and he needs to solve it
sir I didn't touch the workshop just
like you asked although I can't imagine
just part of the music or should I be
worried about that
I can't imagine the mess that's inside
also if you care so much for that room
maybe you should pay more attention to
where you leave the keys I brought them
back to your office have a nice day okay
yeah yeah seriously what the hell
happened to that door what have I done
in this house what am I doing with my
life
down in the basement the children chance
for a stray it's rain for a chance
something chance I don't know they did
something what's that sound hello oh hi
okay oh hey whoa again hey how's it
going there are you doing it okay so
that's cool click it's a little brighter
I don't look so good but apparently
we're in the age of electricity one
below knee prosthesis how the heck did
they Frick up the I don't know what this
okay but nothing too horrible in the
bathroom over here okay so I'm whoa hey
Wow hi there Oh oh my god what is it
that one oh geez hello wow I have got
some lovely artwork
am I the artist am i the artist that's
kind of going bonkers around here oh hi
how's it going
stumbling here and there something
everywhere and galactic strand opening
in flames disastrous fire at the new
departments story leaves dozens fighting
for their lives
oh good the music stopped sir okay the
long awaited opening blah blah blah
exact number contigs not two terminals
of his estimated leasing dealt with
people huh whoa smash that up for some
reason
dang so something tragic happened in
this guy's life obviously lost family
lost his wife whoa whoa Lenny Vinny and
partners got a rat problem fast
efficient and discreet to call us now
forget about it I don't think you're
talking about the animal rats
yeah probably best I don't go in there
that that doesn't seem too fun okay so I
gotta find keys to the boom hi how's it
going there hello I don't have a
flashlight or anything okay cool
oh god oh god oh it's so my god that is
so weird
what's wrong with your face is he is he
like uh you know there's some people
that have a genetic deficiency where
they grow hair all over the face that
kind of looks like what that's all about
oh man then I shouldn't I couldn't be so
rude if that's case uh anyway oh hello
hi oh this is gonna end well
oh look they're friends good friend oh
god they're not friends they're not
friends oh well you just ran into the
wolf why'd you do that
oh god is that how the traditional story
ended horribly okay
all right then mosey on down this is
cheerful this is delightful
oh good oh what's done Oh
I I know bad sign when I see it I don't
think that was good sign
oh hey hey there oh this is not oh god
what is that it's so print this game is
really really really pretty what is this
I know you're not colorblind a day out
of the naked eye pink Oh was I
criticizing oh my god
am I an artist that just criticizes
daughters painting what an [ __ ]
you're a douche whoa the mom doesn't
look so happy
well doctor doesn't look like oh god the
toy soldier child missing oh this is
starting to paint a picture here Oh
family ain't doing so good
Oh God oh lordy Lou oh man oh you're so
weird oh okay I'll get out of here now
all just be on the way there's a singing
video gum drops
okay so this might be the key to the
thing down here oh okay
there's paint ahh Wow
Oh deep breaths remember you're
professional it's just the first few
strokes then you're over the hump what's
so hard about that
well apparently a lot of things
apparently you're a jackass artist too
hi okay so oh that's a lot of ink a lot
of ink from my paintings that seemed a
little significant should I get started
here should I start Willy whacking away
nothing apparently why is that locked
it's not a good sign
Wow okay all right so I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna do much here maybe this is
gonna develop as the game goes along dan
there's a lot of drawers anything
anything anything anything to prevent me
from going into the basement which I
don't want to go into cuz I know there's
gonna be horrible things down there oh
gosh
it's definitely good at setting up a
scenario okay into the base when we go I
don't know where it's gonna be like that
huh oh oh oh
oh okay
just out of reach huh okay thank you for
that that was cool
glad you did that what are you gonna do
next some behind the windows here oh oh
you're a dick
oh you're a douche oh hi did I paint you
oh well this looks cheerful except for
all the what might be blood going in
circles
oh no is this gonna be a PT scenario
just turn this off gonna save
electricity you know I'm not made of
money
part of my douchey yes to my family I
guess
well there's not even the door in this
one is there anything for me to actually
inspect around here well I don't know
the code I'll just maybe that's clues to
the code somewhere around here hello
save the date of that probably would be
the code but I can't beat that nothing
nothing there squeak no okay well this
was a waste of time I think I'll just be
on my way
go home well I am home I goes ah 485
thank you demons you're certainly
helpful 485 it is good the whispering it
really adds a nice touch I really like
the sinister sounds emanating from the
environment the past holds back that
have fought alone the most beautiful
piece of art doesn't have mine
is killing me so so will you marry me oh
no no I won't uh those so corny okay
oh never forget never do forget what
that this door was here oh this is so a
PT scenario hello
a once great artist new painting laughed
out of galleries oh oh the man has been
through a lot lately and obviously it
has taken a toll on him still if we were
to remain silent and pretend this was
even remotely acceptable we would be
doing the artist a disservice
so they laughed at him very hard
ha ha your wife and maybe daughter died
son daughter I'll say daughter hi how's
it go oh you have no flashlight oh no
flashlight all right no flashlights have
no pleasure Oh Kizzy hello
go to the light that's just what it
wants me to do it just wants me to go to
the light that's what it wants me to do
dust mice even in my lungs there's
always more grotesque vermin dirt what
does that mean I think you might be
going a little bit out of your mind
Oh another light in the darkness hi hi
there how's it going hey okay well all
right well I mean let's
okay oh I don't think I like this I
think there's a bunch of baloney I don't
even know how long this game is I mean I
know it's early access but I really
don't know how long if it's going to be
finished in one experience or one oh oh
oh oh was that always like that oh oh
the baby doll hey who the heck do you
think you are in my house placing
yourself a horrifying goop trapped we're
gonna go again huh
maybe maybe mayor council mayor hack you
too I'm sure that I'm sure it says hack
there while it is true that some artists
progressed beyond their times in this
becoming comprehensible for contemporary
critics it is my opinion that this
simply isn't the case well it hurts me
to say this loo this hasn't progressed I
would go as far to say that if anything
what we are witnessing is artists
artistic regression thanks your input is
well noted
much
[ __ ] you okay okay okay all right
oh I was gonna close it anyway thanks
for getting ahead of me okay
okay all right this looks good that's
very well lit that seems to want to lead
me towards that but I'm no fool I'm no
fool
hi I'm a horror expert I know exactly
what it wants me to do it oh my god
screeching arsonists echoing screams
they stop at nothing I won't go down
easy I seem to be going down several
places well hi how's it going
Stu danger did they just jump into the
fire what why don't know that right why
did they done do that why they don't do
this then I am NOT gonna question your
reasons can I crouch this chest under I
don't think I could open it anyway all
right let's see what you got
bring it on oh yeah how's it you just
used your paint down a little bit oh so
scared
that's all you're gonna do throw a book
Jamie whoa that don't look good that
does not look happy yeah where are their
eyes all bleeding also why are they
hanging why is any of this why was this
painted yeah all righty then
cool so far so a ver egde I mean this is
supposed to be things spooky it's is
supposed to be spooky is this game
trying to spook me
what does it think I am a big bubble
blowing baby I'm a man I'm a manly man
who's seen hundreds if not thousands of
horror games in my time I know my way
around a few scary situations okay it's
been a while it took me six months to be
able to hold a pen again it's been a
while it took me six months to be able
to hold a pen again but I finally did it
it still hurts but the pain is just
bearable enough for me to jot down a few
lines the things we take for granted wow
that's deep I think I better rest some
more before I put ancient philosophers
to shame oh okay you were being
sarcastic to yourself hello oh man I am
losing it or not I am losing no no no no
no no oh good good good you know what
good good I'm glad that's good I'd I'd
prefer it this way who fills me with
such glee oh oh oh no no no don't be
locked yeah don't be locked no don't be
like
okay okay
what was that what was that what was
that I heard that first step is the
hardest was AB I heard that
hello oh it is ratatouille
oh hi that was quick I sometimes hard to
tell what what is a thing and what's not
a thing oh okay this is cookware okay
good okay oh oh okay oh it's locked
oh great I guess I won't be going
anywhere oh good okay why Hey no the
hell you think you're doing hi someone
will come in delivery Girl Scout cookies
Oh No
oh that's so cool
but probably not good first I looked for
a canvas not just any canvas so skin is
that scanning to find it knife Oh God
not one of those bread ones it needed to
be as sharp as a razor something tells
me that's not patton oswalt anymore in
fact and then carefully flayed the skin
you don't have to say it so keep my hand
steady it usually does the opposite of
that what the hell is this what did I
get
Oh God Oh No
stop that what's doing it I don't know
what that was
stop that
no dust mice okay oh this is the things
I found oh good I'm gonna have old
collection of crap oh so now I found it
oh I get it
oh good oh good
Oh blood flamingos flamingos oh hello
first I oh yeah I know about okay so
there's six pieces of skin in total and
then more progress on this masterpiece
of mine
and someone's whispering and I don't
like it oh God
okay I don't know how long this game is
but if there's six pieces of skin then I
I do want to complete this game I really
do so this could be a really fun series
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna continue this game
and it's pretty spoopy and I love it so
thanks again everyone and as always I
will see you in the next video
I got my gun